[Music]
someone said to me recently after
Australia so Chris can you say hi to my
wife after the show do you have a wife
and you came to see me
for people with wives this is for
theater people who don't get cast
[Applause]
or should I get out of school I speak
hyperbolically quite a bit for comedic
effect
it doesn't take a licensed psychologist
to tell you that sums up that's good
buddy Chris my daughter loves your
special love you baby can't believe
you're in jail we're gonna need you to
get real close up on the camo now we are
stuck with these unspeakable Horrors
who am I you're gonna fill me in on what
just happened
my mom she always wanted like a J crew
son instead what she got is the cheapest
escort from Arizona
[Applause]